isn't it you made the guy wait two three
months you only so I actually didn't do
them at that time I was running martial
arts studios in the North Shore of
Massachusetts back then but regardless I
think even though I do plans I would try
to see how a guy treats me like I
personally think if a guy as touching
you a lot in the first couple of dates
he doesn't respect you and he views you
more in a sexual Manner and he's not
looking for a long term that's one of
the red flags that I look out for I just
think once you kind of open the fans box
like a guy's gonna be insulted if you
make him wait that long
having sex on only fans if you're like
for money and then you're not [ __ ]
the guy then that's different if you're
just like
I don't know do it what can I see on
your own events like what am I saying
for me personally
um I I don't have sex on my own friends
I will show some like ex like explicit
content of my body but I don't really
show a lot
but I could see you naked though right
and the same for you yeah I do a lot of
what it's because I was a comedian I
actually started only
um after the relationship how we met
um to do comedy shows so I was like I
was like how do I make money the
pandemic was happening I was a sales rep
in marketing the first thing people are
ditching is their marketing budgets and
I was like I'm gonna owe all this money
back and I'm no longer gonna be making
six figures I need to figure something
out and I always wanted to do social
media and I viewed it as a tool to make
money so I didn't take my underwear off
for the first like eight months and I
did topless comedy shows I did a lot of
like dirty talk videos where I'm like
instructing you but I could be fully
clothed just talking so I was trying to
find the Avenues of giving someone a
sexual experience without actually like
fully exposing everything I think I got
sucked into the industry and it is a
very hard industry did not get sucked
into when you're surrounded by a bunch
of people doing stuff and I think I did
cross the line that I thought I was cool
with at the time and wasn't and so I've
like tried to scale back but like
twerking videos I'm doing a dance and I
have like a robot and then I like go
down to my laundry and it's like or I'm
talking dirty or
right but I'm saying like why should I
respect why is a guy supposed to respect
you more than
you respect yourself
on camera which is cool like listen I'll
do the only fans I think that everybody
got a place in society you know what I'm
saying I'm not trying to control
everybody
listening
people from doing what they want to do I
think that everybody can see what they
want to do if you want to [ __ ] around or
you want to do this you want to cool
whatever I don't care about that all I'm
saying is why do I have to be more
respectful
you don't you absolutely don't but I'm
saying why do you have a standard he's
explaining this is just how men why do
you have a higher standard for the guy
but everybody else can see it
so for whatever the price is yeah I
totally understand that and absolutely
and it sounds like if you were single
and I was single we would not be aligned
and we would not work together and
that's totally okay I also understand
that having and only fans does uh make
the dating pool smaller just like how
you were talking about how only 20 of
men are actually attractive to women I'm
sure not the same amount applies to men
who are attracted to only but okay but
you're looking to get married one day
though right yeah
and you're gonna keep your only fans no
I hope not so you so you only holding on
to the only until you get married
so I don't plan on sticking with the
lines for long this is like Jamie said a
stepping stone where we're using it to
build towards other things like we're
building the podcast but she's building
her comedy career yeah it's just a
stepping stone like with my doing only
fans like growing up
um
I guess poor and where Financial
struggles were really big I grew up on
welfare and fuel assistance prior to
that I grew up in a very rich like
Jewish household and we lost it all
um so Financial Security has been really
important to me and uh I mean listen I'm
for it like pop that [ __ ] yeah
and that's not everything I'm not listen
do that get it get your money do all of
that all I'm saying is
that the price of the brick is is lower
than y'all probably think it is like do
y'all so y'all saying that a guy is
supposed to come through knowing that
y'all gotta own we can see it everybody
can see it because I value my chick well
not everyone because the value that I
have on my check is based off of the
fact yeah that's what I'm trying to say
what's the brick what's the what's the
price it actually it uh it
different girls self things for
different some people sell games for
2.29.
I started with a 30 monthly subscription
price and then on my page there was
everything was like basically a spicy
Instagram page
thirty dollars I made 20 grand in my
first month and she had a it's only fans
and hers was like three dollars yeah so
I think a lot of people undervalue that
and part of the way I grew uh blew up on
Tick Tock is I was teaching girls how to
make money and my biggest thing was
cells personality sells more and like
the more you withhold the less you do
like the more they're like they want to
buy to see and they're always like
wondering what else they can see so I
was teaching girls like don't show
anything if you're gonna show stuff
don't do it right away like ease people
into it so that you have like you can
make money so if you have a cute 24 year
old girl and she wants to start
how much can she anticipate making like
how do in terms of a business in general
it really depends on what she's willing
to do if is she willing to Market
herself like is she willing to really go
ham and promote herself on a tick tock
Twitter primarily Tick Tock how can you
spot yourself as the podcast so like if
you go to our social media we do talk
about stuff that kind of gets people in
and where it's open but we're doing a
comedy videos stand up
um collabs on like comedy sketches the
podcast all of that traffic the more
traffic we get the more people are
funneled to our page I
don't agree with like promoting and just
being like subscribed to my friends I
think playing like the long game where
people are like oh wait she has fans and
doesn't expect it but y'all right
yeah I guess yeah right
I think a lot of the conversations that
I have with men personally they're not
at they're not like insecure about it or
they're like they're totally open to it
yeah
oh absolutely but I think that there's a
lot of men who are like in relationships
that I've heard that talk about it and
they're like get your bag do it I'm
comfortable with what it is what do you
think they're gonna tell you
listen babe I'm insecure
um
that bothers me like what do you think
that they're gonna tell you they telling
you what you want to hear in order for
you to be able to do what you need them
to do yeah some don't some are very like
don't do if you're gonna date me you
can't do it and I'm like are you gonna
supplement that income so I can get away
take me away from all this I I would be
happy like I don't want to have to do it
but it's the fact that I get to travel I
get to do what I want we're growing the
podcast my brother was struggling with
homelessness for like the last year and
I took my savings for moments and I
moved him down here I got in an
apartment and gave him like a safe space
that now he can grow and build and I
think that that's like a really
beautiful thing and I would rather be
able to have that help my family grow
myself
no I'm saying a guide I could take you
away from that
I'm looking forward he can buy your
freedom a provider I mean we could put
the label on or whatever but you know he
can buy them I don't know right right he
frees you from having to do that so then
so then you become yeah well the goal is
that hopefully the podcast replaces that
income and then we don't have to do it
and then I'm moving forward having
conversations with men that are much
different
but you can't erase
that's content though right that I've
done in the past no
yeah I mean it's not like um I just I
feel like it's not for everyone and I
don't think all women should do it I
feel like it has a place in society
that's an unpopular opinion it is placed
but it's just like this is how men think
even the guys that say they're okay with
it like I was talking to adam22 you know
and he was saying how um I mean
sometimes is different than what you're
saying like all the players he knows the
boyfriends will start off being like Oh
I'm okay with it and then later like
down the road they break either they
want like a cut of the money or they
want they want to restrict what they do
and I think that's a conversation I
think some people do why do they want to
cut the money because they are actually
participating in it like in the videos
and stuff either both and just because
they're like well if my girl's doing it
and you're making money off of it then I
want to make money off your body video
yeah yeah exactly anyway so let's say I
meet a girl and I and we're dating and
then she tells me on the third date
she's like Hey listen Lead You Know by
the way
you know I got this apartment you know
life was hard I had to get it out the
mud I'd be like okay so then six dates
in I'm like hey you know I've been
taking you out to dinner or what's up
with a cutter though like how is that is
that how it is some guys view like you
selling your body is selling their body
so they're like if you're selling my
body and it's they're talking about you
then I should deserve a cut because
that's my girl my body but it's like
okay my ex would write out the psycho
dramas like so you know how like the
beginning of a scene they have like a
story line and the pizza man comes and
delivers it like some people really care
about that and if you can build up like
a storyline that makes it seem like it's
not and then they they're more likely to
open the private message that's paid for
so you send like some freedoms he would
come up with like the marketing strategy
of all right we're gonna go here and
this is what you're gonna do and he'll
write out like the script and have
everything ready and he would like film
for me and like do that and he'd set up
and he like love it he's like no you're
fine and I was like all right cool PS5
for your birthday I was like you want a
pair of J's what do you want babe like
thank you for participating and helping
me and like supporting me
I know it's weird but you're really
sorry no you're selling yourself short
in what way
I think you under the wrong tutelage I
really do the one wrong what tutelage I
think that you need to nah that's a
whole another conversation no no
question oh I have a question I know
about the right tutelage yeah me too
I think that what is tulips I know I'm
not thinking
I believe that you can be a lot more
successful and I think that you're
probably selling yourself short
I I'm not really sure that you got the
right guidance I think that if you had
the right guidance and the right person
um
where did she get she got 20K the first
time you said 20K the first month I had
5 000. I had 5 000 Instagram followers 2
000 Twitter followers and that's it
but the reason I was able to make so
much money I think is because I played
the role like I'm a comedian and you
typically wouldn't see this and then you
have to I spent a hundred dollars for a
five minute Tom like topless comedy set
like I'm in shorts and just my boobs are
out and I'm like telling jokes to the
camera and people were buying it I got
recognized by a huge comedian as a
result I had articles written about it
as being like a comedian only ones I
took all of that free time that I was
able to provide myself and I was like
you're up in the head like you got a lot
to work on yourself I'm gonna take this
time to heal and like do therapy and
figure out what my value is as a person
because I don't think when I decided to
do only fans that I was a secure human
person like I wasn't secure in myself in
a lot of ways and I think it provided a
opportunity for me to not be so worried
about money because I was in sales I was
doing the corporate job I had brown hair
I dressed conservatively like I did all
of that and I was hustling and busting
my ass I was like I can't do this and
struggle and I wasn't able to get out of
the financial hole that I was in from
college so it just gave me that
opportunity and so I think I would love
for a person and then my person who I
would eventually marry to look at all of
the work that I've done as a result and
not completely dismiss me because of
doing so I had a question when you're
struggling for money as many of you know
I was just banned on Tick Tock and we
are demonetized on a daily basis on this
platform if you want to help please
consider sending a super thanks below
every donation helps and it helps make
what we do possible